restaurants qui ont fermé que
c'est 10 fois plus que
d'habitude. Sébastien
Desrosiers.
- Plus que quelques heures
avant le jour J.
IAN GOREN, serveur,
restaurant Madame Thaï
- Ça fait longtemps qu'on attend
ça, puis on est en train de tout
préparer pour que ce soit
la meilleure réouverture
possible.
BRIGITTE GAGNÉ, propriétaire,
restaurant Péché Matinal
- Ça arrive au bon moment,
je vous dirais, là. Par contre,
c'est sûr qu'on doit recommencer
au niveau d'équipe et tout ça.
Il y a beaucoup de travail
à faire.
- Ce restaurant ne sera ouvert
que cinq jours par semaine
puisqu'il manque d'employés
en cuisine, résultat
de la pandémie.
- De plus en plus, on perdait
les employés, donc nos équipes,
notre équipe nous donnaient,
là, un à un leur démission
parce qu'ils changeaient
de métier, de domaine.
- Mais elle l'a échappée belle;
elle pourra rouvrir.
D'autres n'ont tout simplement
pas survécu, dont le Grumman 78.
Le populaire restaurant de tacos
de Saint-Henri a été forcé
de fermer en octobre dernier.
Son mythique camion de rue
a été remisé.
GAËLLE CERF, copropriétaire,
restaurant Grumman 78
- On s'est sentis obligés
de fermer et, maintenant,
réflexion faite, je sais que
c'était la meilleure chose
qu'on pouvait faire.
- Les affaires allaient
pourtant si bien avant la crise
qu'un autre établissement devait
ouvrir à Pointe-Saint-Charles.
La fermeture des salles
à manger a été fatale.
- Si on avait tenu le coup,
on aurait peut-être un quart de
million de dollars de dettes.
- À Montréal, 966 établissements
n'ont pas renouvelé leur permis
de restauration cette année.
C'est plus de 15 %
des restaurants de Montréal
qui cessent leurs activités.
Cette proportion est de 13 %
dans l'ensemble du Québec.
- Le véritable portrait,
on l'aura peut-être davantage
l'année prochaine.
- L'Association restauration
Québec s'inquiète. Certains
devront connaître un été
exceptionnel pour maintenir
la tête hors de l'eau.
L'industrie est probablement
la plus affectée
par la pandémie.
FRANÇOIS MEUNIER,
Association restauration Québec
- Avant la crise de la COVID,
l'industrie connaissait
ses deux meilleures années
depuis des décennies,
depuis 30 ans, en fait.
Et pour la première fois,
les ventes des restaurants
au Québec dépassaient en
performance toutes les autres
provinces canadiennes.
- Je tiens pas à ouvrir
un autre Grumman.
- Gaëlle Cerf a d'autres
projets. D'ici là, elle continue
de s'impliquer pour que
les restaurateurs soient
mieux soutenus et pour que
le personnel soit mieux payé.
- Je regarde mon ancien local,
juste là, et je sais qu'il y a
des gens qui l'ont repris,
je crois que ça va être
un restaurant, je leur
souhaite beaucoup de bonheur,
parce qu'on s'est fait
beaucoup de fun ici.
- Beaucoup de plaisir en vue,
mais ce ne sont pas
les défis qui manquent.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, M